foreign
so
here
all right thank you ladies and gentlemen
are your next witness
yes your honor plaintiff calls edward
white okay thank you
penalty of law yes
good afternoon sir
good afternoon mr white
good afternoon counselor
will you state your name full name for
the record
yes edward white
where do you reside
los angeles california
how are you employed
many years ago i founded edward white
and company certified public accountants
and i am the managing and senior partner
of the firm
what is a certified public accounting
firm
a certified public accounting firm is
authorized
by particular state in my case
california
to audit financial information and to
certify
the statements related there too
what's the nature of the work that's
done at edward white and company
it's diversified
it includes providing
tax and related compliance services that
is to do the tax returns for the clients
that's both fiduciary corporate
individual as well as partnership work
we also are involved in providing
financial statements for financial
institutions
and for governmental agencies
we in addition to that have a business
management department and provide a wide
variety of services in that capacity
are you the edward white of edward white
and company
yes i am
who do you employ
we employ a very talented group of
professionals
that have really amazing credentials
they have graduate degrees from nyu and
usc in business administration as well
as taxation
many of my colleagues have been with the
firm for over 25 years in one case for
35 years i'm very proud to be associated
with this group of people
who are your principal clients
we represent approximately 100 high net
worth individuals and the companies that
they own and operate in addition to that
we do work for government agencies such
as the department of justice
the state of alaska the state of
california and the city of long beach
what's your educational background
i started my college career
utilizing the
gi bill i served four years in the air
force and was fortunate enough to have
that opportunity
my undergraduate degree was in business
administration
and i have a master's degree in business
administration from the university of
southern california
after completing my
graduate degree at usc
i studied
several i took several tax classes
corporate fiduciary estate and gift
and
subject matters such as that
do you have any other
experience with education
yes i was a former professor of
accounting and taxation
at california state university located
in los angeles california
what kind of work do you personally do
the work i do is primarily transaction
oriented
acquisitions of companies dispositions
that's buying or selling a company
arranging financing with a large
financial institutions
consulting with clients where they feel
it's appropriate for me to be involved
assisting my colleagues as i mentioned
to you we have approximately 100 high
net worth individual clients
and there's always something that that i
can contribute to
do you hold any certifications
yes i'm certified in financial forensics
by the american institute of certified
public accountants
i'm also
a member of the american institute of
certified public accounts and the
california society of certified public
accounts and of course i'm a certified
public accountant
what are financial forensics
that's an attempt to ascertain not only
the facts but what transpired
as it relates to financial activity so
you do a study based upon financial
records you then look at contracts
you look at other financial information
in an attempt to
once again not only ascertain what the
results were but what caused the results
have you ever previously testified in
court
yes i've been accepted as an expert
witness in both the california court and
the federal courts
and i have testified
in matters involving the department of
justice and the fbi
okay
do you serve on any boards or have you
served on any boards
objection relevance your honor this
witness is not being proffered as an
expert in this case all right wasn't
that is this just a fact witness and not
an expert in fact witness and
goes to credibility i'll sustain the
objection i think we can move on okay
do you know mr depp
yes i do how'd you come to know mr depp
i met him because he was introduced to
me by a senior executive at the bank of
california richard smith
do you work with mr deb
yes i do in what capacity we are his
business management firm
how long have you served in that
capacity by approximately six years
what does that role involve
of
processing managing his financial
affairs
as you know mr deb is an amazing talent
internationally acclaimed for his work
but he relegated his financial
activities to me and my colleagues so we
provide a wide variety of services for
him
do you do this kind of work for other
people yes we do
numerous other clients
when did you first become involved with
mr deb
approximately six years ago
after the introduction from mr smith
what was the nature of the work that you
were
that you were to perform for him
initially it was to perform a forensic
study
evaluate his financial affairs and to
formulate recommendations on how he
could manage his affairs in a more
advantageous manner
after you conducted
that analysis what did you do
i i met with mr deb the purpose of which
was to share with him
uh the results of our findings and to
make recommendations in how he could
resolve the issues he was confronting
when was that meeting
that meeting was on april 21st 2016.
who called the meeting i did i called
the meeting because i felt it was
appropriate to meet with mr deb
and to discuss his affairs
and to provide him with
opportunities and plans
and strategies to resolve the issues he
was confronting
where was the meeting held it was held
at his offices in los angeles california
do you know approximately what time it
began it began at approximately 7 30
and my recollection is there were seven
people in attendance
including mr deb and myself
was alcohol served at the meeting not to
my recollection i don't recall any
alcohol being consumed
did mr depp stay for the entirety of the
meeting oh yes he was very interested in
the contents he asked very thoughtful
questions
um he was fully engaged
and fully sensitive to the matters that
we were discussing
did there come a time when mr mr depp
didn't participate in the meeting
no he was very actively involved he did
excuse himself on two or three occasions
it's my understanding that he was going
to
contact miss heard
and attempt to respond to her concerns
and also address the fact that this was
an extremely important meeting
and that involved his financial
viability and that he felt it imperative
to stay and address the issues i was
discussing with him
when did the meeting conclude at
approximately 9 30.
so it went for approximately two hours
at the conclusion of the meeting
what did you deserve what did you
observe as to mr depp
um that he was fully engaged once again
he thanked me profusely
for not only addressing the problems
but he was excited about the fact that
was a strategy and plan to resolve the
problems
did he appear impaired to you in any way
no to the contrary
i found him to be i'm sorry sir there
was an objection all right what was the
objection i'm sorry
leading
just i asked him for his observation
well if you want to ask different i'll
sustain that objection but you can ask
another question did you make any
observations as to mr
uh
depp's potential impairment
it was readily apparent to me that he
was actively involved in the
conversation
he asked very thoughtful and prudent
questions
he was genuinely interested and once
again when he left he thanked me
profusely for not only addressing the
issues but formulating a strategy and
plan to resolve them in a successful
manner
did you have
did you play any role
on mr def's behalf with respect to the
dissolution
of his marriage to ms heard
yes i was actively involved in
negotiations of the
separation and the marriage dissolve
what role did you play in those
negotiations
well in my capacity as his business
manager i understood his financial
capacity
and the tax implications associated with
it
so i was actively involved
in
addressing
uh those issues as they were forthcoming
from council
um you mentioned tax implications what
are you talking about there
excuse me you think you may just mention
tax implications what are you talking
about there well
what i was talking about is that
when
misheard began
the negotiations
she was asking for approximately four
million dollars
that balance then was increased hearsay
black foundation hearsay
these are requests made by miss hurdler
council
in a conversation in communications
as a result
of your
involvement
on behalf of mr depp in the negotiation
what was your understanding of what ms
heard was looking for
she initially was looking for a
consideration of 4 million
but her demand continually increased
it went from four million dollars to
five million dollars
then it went from five million dollars
to five and a half million dollars
then it went to seven million dollars
and then
it was seven million dollars and she
required
demanded that mr depp also pay five
hundred thousand dollars to her
attorneys
then
after
that consideration
she also said that all the community
liabilities
that were accumulated during the course
of the marriage which approximately
there's no objection sir whatever
there's objection i'm sorry if you can't
hear it i'll let you know okay thank you
and no problem goes into his allegations
of what she said what your honor just
obstructed sustain the objection on that
he has no foundation to suggest that no
knowledge of that governor
i understand that
is understanding all right i'll overrule
the objection go ahead
may i continue
she'll tell you yes yes
yes
he learns very well
so the next demand
was that all the community liabilities
that were unresolved approximately 13.5
million dollars
that mr depp had to pay those
liabilities in its entirety
so at that point
she was demanding 14 million 250 000
of consideration
and then it got worse
the next amend
was that all of this consideration
be paid to her free of taxation
and counselor for him to pay 14 million
fourteen million two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to miss hurt
that would require him to earn
approximately thirty million dollars so
far beyond the scope so far beyond his
foundation of what was discussed i'll
sustain that last last answer all right
next
question did you make a proposal as to
how payments would be made to misheard
yes i did and they were initially
contemplated to be paid directly to the
charities the children's hospital los
angeles for the benefit of the children
who required severe medical service and
to the aclu
during the course of the negotiations
one of the demands because the contract
changed
was that the payments be made directly
to miss heard
did you
have
any personal
uh involvement with either the aclu or
the children's hospital yes i did what
was that
mr depp directed me
to issue two 100 000 checks
directly to the children's hospital los
angeles i knew that he was involved and
supported their efforts
and appreciated his service in addition
to that he directed me to contribute one
hundred thousand dollars to aclu
in accordance with his instructions
my colleagues drafted the checks i
execute them and they were delivered to
the two charities
did you
continue making payments to either of
those charities on ms herd's behalf
no in fact i was chastised for making
the payments
by ms herd's counsel and told that the
payments in the future had to go
directly to her this is clear hearsay
he's not answering the question i would
i would ask for you to instruct him to
answer the question and not expound upon
his i'll sustain as to hear you say next
question
what role did you play
with respect to the payments ultimately
made to miss her
we
supplied the payments to ms heard
in accordance with the agreement
either on or before the date in which
they were required to be paid
the
first payments made to misheard was two
million dollars in 2017.
then in april of 2017 another payment of
one million dollars made payable
directly to ms heard was made
then in august of 2017 another million
dollars was paid directly to ms hurt
then in november five hundred thousand
dollars would pay directly to ms heard
my colleagues drafted those checks i
executed they were delivered on a timely
basis therefore in 2017
she was paid 4.5 million dollars
directly paid to her
then on february 1 of 2018
she was paid the final installment of
2.3 million dollars for total payments
that went directly to ms heard of 6.8
million dollars
do you know when this lawsuit was filed
yes it was filed in march 1 2019.
were the payments that were made on mr
depp's behalf uh directly to ms hurd the
only economic benefit she received
jackson leading
i haven't heard them
i
i'll overrule the objection process now
go ahead
uh were
were the payments made on uh
to misheard the only economic benefits
that you received from the settlement
agreement no as i shared with you
earlier
mr depp
was required to pay five hundred
thousand dollars to mrs herd's council
which he did in a timely respectful
manner
he was also required to pay all the
community liabilities
which
accumulated during their 15-month
marriage
was approximately
13 million 500 000
so he paid all the community liabilities
she paid none of them that's why you
have to aggregate
the money that was paid directly to her
the money was paid to her to the
charities on her behalf the money was
paid to her attorneys and the relief of
all these liabilities that she had that
he had to satisfy that's why i said to
you counselor that the total
consideration paid to her was 14 million
250 000
and she demanded that that payment be
made
free of taxation that mr depp would have
to satisfy all the tax liabilities
how long were they married for
they were married for 15 months
okay um
were the payments that went to misheard
the only
payments that you've made on mr depp's
behalf
no we satisfied all of his obligations
so it was very customary for us to pay
everything that mr depp was obligated to
pay
are you familiar with an entity known as
2020 wine merchants
yes i am
what you why are you familiar with it
it's a prominent purveyor of wine in los
angeles foundation
hearsay
i don't see the hearsay but i foundation
at this point
continue
sure
all right
i think where we left off is i asked how
were you familiar with 2020 wine
merchants and if that's not what i asked
you that's what i'm asking you now
2020 is a
highly recognized purveyor of wine in
los angeles along with other companies
what involvement if any did you have
with 2020
i satisfied
the liabilities that mr deb incurred
which at the
dissolve of their marriage was
approximately 160 000
do you continue to pay mr
depp's wine bell
uh yes i do we pay all of his
obligations but his wine bill has shrunk
to virtually zero
um
because
he does not consume that much in the way
of wine he's made a few gifts around
christmas time
but his wine bill has gone to virtually
zero
are you familiar with a spanish wine
known as vega cecilia yes
how are you familiar with that
i know that it is a
very expensive wine
and that i know that miss heard enjoyed
drinking the wine
how much does it cost
the cost of the wine is approximately
five hundred dollars a bottle
were you ultimately uh charged with uh
paying for
the
wine that was served on
at the birthday party on april 21 2016.
yes i was we read the payment foundation
i'll overrule the objection that's fine
how many bottles of vega
cecilia were served
at a miss herd's request
she ordered five bottles of the wine
and eight bottles of other wine so a
total of 13 bottles of wine
thank you mr white i have no other
questions
this time cross-examination
thank your honor
good afternoon mr white good afternoon
counselor your firm has been paid
millions of dollars by mr depp and his
company since you were first retained in
2016 correct correct
and in fact you're being paid for the
time that you're sitting on that witness
stand today aren't you
no
well you've char you charge the time
that you spent um in connection with
legal proceedings in this case correct
that's correct but i charge for my time
yeah and i it's the same you answer my
questions in fact you charge 710 an hour
for your time don't you counsel if you
let me complete my answer i'm happy to
respond
sir
please just please try to stick to the
question that i'm asking you you've had
you've had your chance to go well beyond
the question being asked but if you
could just please stick to the question
i'm asking you would go a lot
faster could you i don't think your
microphone was on there
it's not it's not really a
badgering it's not it the ejection but
that's that's all right so just if you
could answer the question that's asked
okay thank you
thank you all right
let me let me start over sir you're you
you charge mr depp seven hundred and ten
dollars an hour for the work that you do
for him don't you
that is my standard rate for all clients
and yes i do charge that rate to mr deb
and you gave a deposition in this case
you remember that on around february 2nd
2022
yes
and
that day you charged mr depp 710 dollars
an hour for the time that you spent
giving testimony that day didn't you
yes i did
and
you charge mr depp seven hundred and ten
dollars an hour for
anything that you do in connection with
his account don't you
yes i do
you have about six people working on mr
depp's account
correct
yes
and
whether through you or one of your
colleagues your main contact with mr
depp and his companies is his sister
christy dembrowski correct
no
who was your main contact
mr deb
one of your colleagues maintains active
communication with christy dombrowski
correct
could you ask a question again counselor
one of your colleagues maintains active
communication with christy dambrowski
correct no
approach all right yes sir
thank you
mr white i've handed you the transcript
from your deposition that you gave in
this case on february 2nd 2022. you
remember that we did it over zoom
yes i do okay and you you swore to tell
the truth in that deposition as best you
can correct yes okay can you turn to
page 116
of your deposition certainly
did you say 16 counselor 116 116
okay i have it and now you just answered
no to my question about your colleagues
maintaining communication with christy
dombrowski but at your deposition just
two months ago on line 11 of page 116
the question is what about christy
dambrowski the answer that you gave is i
do not i haven't spoken to christy in
some time one of my colleagues probably
maintains an active basis of
communications between her and our firm
did i read that right
yes but you that that's that was me
i read that right sir now part of the
services that you provide that your firm
provides to mr depp is to pay his his
the bills to his doctors correct yes
and you make payments relating to
maintenance or damages to his properties
correct
yes
you were contacted in early 2016 right
you testified to that
to to do work on behalf of mr depp
we were engaged in march 2016. if that's
your question right right around
february 10th is that when you were
first contacted
i do not recall the date and you said
you were introduced by executives a guy
named richard smith at the bank of
california
yes mr depp owed a significant amount of
money to the bank of california at that
time correct
no
he owed money to the bank of california
correct i do not recall that he had an
active indebtedness with the bank of
california he had other uh commercial
loans but not with the bank of
california
and after you were brought on you
developed an understanding that mr
depp's financial status was very
challenging correct
it was challenging but we had an ability
to resolve the problems if they were
properly addressed he had liquidity
problems right
he had substantial assets in excess of
his liabilities but he had short-term
obligations and need to be satisfied
let me just ask that again with the time
that you were brought on he had
liquidity problems correct
can you define liquidity for me i'm i'm
asking you at the time he was brought on
he had liquidity problems correct
i would define
the term liquidity as where the
short-term assets
are less than the short-term excuse me
are
less than short-term liabilities and if
that's how you define liquidity i would
agree
in
layman's terms terms that that i can
understand because i don't i don't speak
all the kind of business school terms
that you speak
he didn't have enough money at the time
correct he was spending more than he was
bringing in correct
yes
and you gave him advice about how he
could hopefully get out of that problem
correct
yes okay and
just to be clear uh mr white because
you've testified to to some degree of
knowledge about
um
wine that you you you allege that miss
heard requested so you seem to have some
some knowledge of of mr depp's spending
miss her didn't she didn't buy any of
the dozens of properties that mr depp
owned correct
correct he owns the assets prior to
their marriage she didn't pay five
million dollars to blast hunter
thompson's ashes out of a cannon did she
not to my knowledge she didn't buy a
yacht that she couldn't afford and then
have to sell it to jk rowling did she
not to my knowledge
now let's talk about that meeting on
april 21st 2016. you said the meeting
started it's about 7 30 p.m
yes and lasted until maybe 9 30 is that
right yes
and you have no idea
no personal knowledge where mr depp went
after he left that meeting do you
that is correct i did not go with him i
went home
and at that meeting mr depp was given
some catastrophic news about his
business correct
he was given news that he needed to
address a number of financial issues but
i had a strategy and plan to fully
resolve them
that news that he was given that night
was catastrophic wasn't it
no
may i approach your honor yes sir
thank you
mr white let's do this again with
another
under oath series of statements you gave
testimony in the uk trial did you not
yes
and that testimony was under oath
correct yes all right and in front of
you i have your testimony from the uk
trial and you gave that testimony on
behalf of mr depp correct
i gave it honestly okay
you gave it on behalf of mr depp
correct you were one of his witnesses
called that is correct okay can you
please turn to page 865.
and it's just the second page of the
document upper left before that the
questions are talking about this meeting
on april 21st 2016
and you were asked the question question
now mr depp was given some catastrophic
news about his business answer
that is correct did i read that right
you did but remember that that was just
i got a chance to answer my question sir
i did not define that sir mister you'll
have a chance the attorney will get back
up and redirect you okay so if you just
answer his question that's fine and the
reason i'm asking sir is because you
just gave the exact opposite testimony
here so that's that's why we pointed
that out
now you at this meeting you had a
discussion about his financial affairs
and a necessity to formulate a revised
business strategy and plan correct
yes
and you talked about the following
financial information you talked about
bank obligations and tax liabilities
right yes which means money you owe to
either the government or banks correct
yes
you talked about assets that he needed
to sell correct yes
properties and things like that that he
needed to sell to generate money
correct
you talked about ways to reduce spending
correct
yes
and you talked about
how to get new engagements
correct
yes how to get new gigs right
not how to get them but then i encourage
them to get them i'm not an agent i
appreciate that curious engagement and
understood
you talked about the need to
get new gigs to generate additional
money to help
uh address these financial woes that he
was experiencing correct yes
you also told him at that meeting that
um
his taxes he hadn't paid taxes in years
correct
no that's not correct that he had not
paid any taxes in years is not correct
that that
he was significantly delinquent in
federal tax obligations dating back
years correct
i don't know how you're defining years
there were delinquent liabilities i
addressed them
and formulated a plan
and you talked about the significant
delinquent tax liabilities that would
run into the millions of dollars for
taxes unpaid correct that is correct
and so after receiving these this
catastrophic news as we discussed you
have no idea where mr depp went when he
walked out of the doors of his office
correct
i do not know where he went can you pull
up plaintiff's exhibit 936 please
and mr white i'm not going to um this is
a long a long document
um
that we can we can scroll through but
what i'll i'll
represent to you and
michelle can sort of scroll down is that
these these appear to be mr depp's tax
returns for mr depp and his companies
from 2009 to 2019. do you see that
yes
and
um these are our returns as part of your
um role as his cpa
firm now his business manager firm now
you your firm prepares these tax returns
correct yes and you maintain these tax
returns in the ordinary course of your
business correct that is correct
your honor i know there's going to be
plenty of redaction to do but i just
would like to move these into evidence i
don't plan to publish them or anything
at this point
objection you want to approach
all right so 936 will come into evidence
but i'll wait for redactions and they
will not be published okay thank you
your honor
now mr white you
you understood that
mr depp
showed up hours late for work on pirates
five correct
that is not correct
are you familiar with tracy jacobs
yes that's mr mr depp's uh former agent
correct
yes and at the time that she was serving
as his agent part of her job
responsibilities to the best of your
understanding was to communicate with
you about mr depp's financial affairs
correct
to the extent she had knowledge right
yes she would communicate and and you
and she did communicate about uh mr depp
correct
during the period of engagement yes we
did communicate
um can you pull up defendants exhibit
874 please michelle
mr white do you
do you see here this text exchange
between you and tracy jacobs
yes and your texts are in in white and
miss jacobs are in blue correct yes
michelle could you please scroll to um
the document that that
is bait stamped dep19246
it's about the fifth or sixth one down
please
mr white do you see here the third text
down from tracy jacobs to you
um
saying thanks i got a call from disney
last week saying he showed up objection
your honor here
it's it's not here it's party opponent
she's his agent we've i'm happy to
approach if you'd like to discuss
and we were back
mr white um we just saw the text that i
started reading do you remember that
text yes okay we're gonna just gonna
show you
uh and move for admission of that that
page of the document with that text um
so i just wanted since you won't see
anything else i just wanted you to
orient yourself that that is the text
that we were just reading okay
fine
you're right
that page or that time you're going to
redact it just that one text thank you
your honor i would move for admission of
this document as i guess we could call
it defendants 874-a okay 874 a with the
redactions all right thank you
mr white um you you just testified uh a
few minutes ago that you you didn't have
any understanding of mr depp showing up
late for work on pirates five but in
fact you received this text from tracy
jacobs that says thanks
i got a call from disney last week
saying he showed up five hours late for
adr work in london for pirates five i
really need to speak to him before he
starts work on his net next project in
la did i read that right
permission to publish this your honor oh
yes i'm sorry thank you
do you want me to do you want me to
respond
i just wanted to ask you if i read that
right that you received this text
message saying in part i got a call from
disney last week
saying he showed up five hours late for
adr work in london for pirates five i
really need to speak to him before he
starts work on this next project in la
did i read that right
i believe you blend it right thank you
now
at some point you became familiar
you can go ahead and take that down
please thank you at some point you
became familiar as you've testified with
what amber planned to do with money that
she got from mr depp in the divorce
correct
it was the understanding from the
beginning the money would be contributed
to charities the two charities the
children's hospital
children's hospital of la
and the aclu correct
that is correct and as we discussed you
wrote checks to those two organizations
that were part of
mr depp's divorce payment but they were
just sent directly to those
organizations correct
yes can you please pull up
defendants exhibit
1639
actually let's do
let's do defendants exhibit um
yeah we'll do 1639
thanks
mr white this is a letter from you to
the aclu foundation dated august 24 2016
correct
yes
and um
as as
part of your your work for your 100
or so high profile high net worth
clients you've helped clients set up
pledged contributions to charities
before correct yes
and sometimes those payments are made
over a period of time correct
yes charitable donations aren't always
paid at once correct
that is correct and when you make
payments on behalf of your clients to
charities
is it customary for you to send a cover
letter like this
in some instances yes and some instances
no okay but in all instances
that there is a signed agreement and an
understanding of when the yeah that
means so that wasn't my question my
question was just is it customary for
you to send a letter like this um and i
think you've answered that and so when
you send letters like this on behalf of
your clients do you do you prepare such
letters in the ordinary course of your
business
in some instances yes and when you in
the instances in which you prepare those
letters do you then maintain those
letters in the ordinary course of your
business
yes
your honor i'd move for admission of
defendants exhibit one six three nine
objection
all right 16 39 in evidence and you can
publish it to the jury thank you
and michelle if you could please just
scroll through mr white i just want you
to see there's the the letter here
um we'll come back to the letter and
then there's there's the check
that you're making out to the aclu
then there's i guess the envelope or
something right
correct okay you can go back to the
letter please
so in this in this
uh
in this cover letter
you
tell the aclu that you're closing a
check for a hundred thousand dollars
and that the donation is being made in
accordance with ms heard's pledged gift
of three and a half million to the aclu
foundation correct
yes and you also write that the check
represents uh
just go ahead the the check represents
uh the first
of multiple scheduled installments
correct
it was my understanding this is going to
contribute
three million
you've asked me a question i'm trying to
do something no i was actually just
asking if that's what you wrote
would you ask the question again yeah
you write this check represents the
first of multiple scheduled installments
to honor the full amount of ms heard's
three and a half million dollar pledge
gift it was my understanding she was
going to contribute the money and that's
okay so i just asked if that's what you
wrote let's i think you've answered that
can we please pull up exhibit 1596.
your honor before we go to the next
exhibit can can i raise an issue okay
sure thanks
mr white is this a letter
similar to what we just looked at for
the aclu
a letter
that you wrote
that accompanied the check that you sent
to the children's hospital of los
angeles foundation yes
and
this uh letter and the whatever payment
or sorry this letter is one that you
would have prepared in the ordinary
course of business correct yes and you
would have maintained this letter in the
ordinary course of business correct yes
um you're on a move for the admission of
exhibit one five nine six all right one
five nine six in evidence you can
publish it to the jury
and mr white this
letter also
says at the bottom that it represents
the check that accompanies this letter
represents the first of multiple
scheduled installments to honor the full
amount of misheard's 3.5 million dollar
pledged gift correct when i composed the
letter that was my understanding that
she was going to give three
possibilities
you're really not answering my question
my question was simply i i understand
that you you want to
you want to speak your own narrative
here but my question was simply that
this letter says that this check
represents the first of multiple
scheduled installments to honor the full
amount of misheard's three and a half
million dollar pledge gift correct
we can both read the letter and answer
yes thank you sir now you hosted a
dinner with mr depp um
and adam waldman in in 2016 correct
i do recall that and that was the first
time that uh
mr death had been introduced to mr
waldman correct
i do not know that the fact now you you
are not an expert on california divorce
law right correct and you're not an
expert on the division of marital
property in california correct
i'm not an expert but i've been actively
involved in numerous cases involving the
disillusionment marriage
and the related proceeds are distributed
to each respected party
now you can't
give any sort of legal opinion
or testimony as to whether or not miss
heard would have been entitled to more
in the divorce settlement with mr death
than she received correct
i'm not an attorney at law okay i don't
have legal opinions
so
you've never met amber heard correct
that is correct the first time you've
ever seen her in person is here in this
courtroom this afternoon correct that's
my recollection and you have no personal
knowledge of whether mr depp engaged in
domestic abuse against my client
correct
i've never witnessed him
involved in any abuse and obviously i
have never met her i could not respond
to that inquiry so the answer to my
question is that it's correct that you
have no personal knowledge of whether mr
death engaged in domestic abuse against
amber hurt
that is correct i have no knowledge
nothing further all right redirect
mr denison
can we pull up
defendants 1596
sir could you read the last line of
your letter
this check represents the first of
multiple scheduled installments to honor
the full amount of ms heard's 3.5
million dollar pledged gift
what was the schedule for those payments
they were scheduled i i don't know the
schedule because i don't have a copy of
any pledge that she made
if that's your question
okay thank you very much
one more question
is mr depp paid all his taxes
yes he has he's fully current with all
of this federal
foreign and state tax obligations thank
you
all right no further questions mr jensen
all right is this witness subject to
recall no
no
all right mr white you're free to go
thank you sir just be very careful
stepping down there okay thank you honor
thank you have a good day
all right your next witness is remote
witness correct
all right
let me just
give him donald
wait a moment
your honor may we just ask what witness
they plan to play i i see a mr connolly
in the lobby so i'm assuming that must
be
that must be the one
okay good
good i'm glad we got that one all right
so
mr conley can you hear me
hello
yes yes sir
yep hi yeah can you turn your camera on
sir
okay there we go there we go
all right sir if you could raise your
right hand
do you swear from tell the truth on a
penalty of law
i did all right
all right and uh good afternoon mr
connolly
good afternoon
and would you please state your full
name for the record
welcome connolly
and mr connolly uh where are you
testifying from at the moment
from home uh essex uk
and and where do you live
i live in essex uk
mr connolly what is your occupation
uh at present um course protection
operative
i've had a couple of professions i'm a
bricklayer at the trade i was in the
corrections facility
pentonville hms prison
but right now yeah i'm a
protection
officer
okay and and can you tell us a little
bit uh just generally
what that means
that means uh
looking after
the personal well-being
a physical well-being
of any client you're detailed to
and how long have you been in the
personal security business
25 years
over the course of those 25 years have
you had any other kinds of jobs
yeah as i said i was a corrections
officer for a majesty prison
okay
are you familiar with the plaintiff in
this case johnny depp
i am yes
and how do you know mr depp
yeah i know mr death
[Music]
along uh maybe about
23 years ago 24 years ago uh i worked
for a company called music and arts the
guy who won that company was jerry judge
uh jerry started working with johnny
way back in the early days
and i was detailed looking after uh
johnny's ex
vanessa parity
and
jack and lily rose johnny's kids and my
my job is just to make sure they were
safe when johnny was at work
so that job
after about a year and a half two years
johnny uh asked me to go over him
directly and we'll find someone else to
do the kid from there and that's how i
came across johnny so that's why that's
how i personally met johnny depp
can you ballpark for us about what year
that was
oh two thousand and
six
okay and can you generally just tell us
a little bit about what you do uh for mr
depp as his security guard
um i will escort johnny to everyday uh
public
places
make sure he's okay make sure
you know he's not in any danger
first of all do the reiki you know you
go along first there's usually a two-man
team it's a two-man detail
you go along do your recce
make sure all the ins and outs are
socket
no compromises any risks involved
assessment
we do the job
i look after them basically i look after
johnny whenever we're in public domain
whenever we're going to be in a public
domain
i will look after johnny
okay and uh and how about the defendant
in this case amber heard are you are you
familiar with miss heard
i am familiar with yeah
i first met miss herb in probably 2 000
and
i don't recall exactly the actual date
probably about 2010
maybe around there
she came into the uk
to do a promotional job for a movie
called drive angry
my boss studied jerry judge asked me to
take the detail
went met amber
started your job amber was with our ex
tosh tasha
and uh
i looked after amber for a week
pleasant week it was fine great
uh does anything
sorry yeah
after that week uh i never seen
amber again until we did the rum diaries
the premiere uh after show where i'm
dying
okay uh so
let's move to the to the rum diary then
uh when did you see miss heard um well
how did you see miss heard in connection
with uh the rum diary
um we were
we've done the rum daily premiere we
went to the after show party
uh
you know i'm busy working doing my job
myself and jerry judge
uh see number across the floor amber
seeing me
just basically come across the floor set
hello how are you doing you know you use
your chit chat you chit chatting for a
minute or two
uh johnny asked me how actually new
amber
explained uh that's the last sport
chamber that night i was too busy
doing my job you know
did you know at the time and uh well
well let's back up for a second where
was that premier
um do you know what i don't recall
i think it was
i think it was an la
okay i think you actually recall
okay
did you know at the time of that uh
premiere in
probably la but possibly somewhere else
um did you know at the time that mr depp
and miss heard were seeing each other
romantically
no i didn't i actually didn't i mean i i
surmised that
there was a spark there you know it
wasn't until uh
maybe
maybe a
few days later a few nights later
we
well i've done a party somewhere
a promotional thing
and
amber and johnny were basically you know
sparking sparking out they were they
were getting together then i i
assumed that you know there was a
romance happening there budding there
you know
okay over the course of
mr depp and miss heard's relationship
with each other
about how often would you say you saw
them together
well in the beginning actually not a lot
you know not a lot uh maybe once a week
yeah
twice a week that i push
but then it started uh well it started
maturing into something in a
relationship
so
more often more often enchantment on you
know
and as as time went on did you have an
opportunity to observe uh how mr deputy
interacted with each other
uh at the beginning um oh you know
lovely dobby everything was great the
honeymoon period was on and it was a
yeah it was good i mean it was great
great to see johnny happy again amber
was you know
lovely charming
as she usually is you know
good as gold
and then things you know things started
to change amber started to change amber
started
getting a bit i would say a bit more
uh feisty uh demanding you know
i could see that amber wanted to wear
the pants in this relationship that was
pretty obvious
and
what in particular made you think that
that you observed personally
um just just the way uh you know if
something wasn't quite right or
uh
amber could uh amber could get a bit
frosty at the drop of a hat
so as time went on you know i could see
them
i could see them change i could see i
could see amber change i could see
johnny getting quieter
uh you get into the car and nobody was
speaking
and you know just things started
changing amber started getting a bit
more
grumpy
how did she uh how did she get along
with you
absolutely fine i i uh
amber was
finding me
amber was never anything but
professional polite
with me you know she was uh no amber was
fine with me
did you ever uh
see or hear
any arguments between mr depp and miss
hurt
uh
when you say see i heard i mean i could
hear at times and
certain accommodations would be staying
out
i could hear
amber yeah screaming you know
i could hear shouting and balling and
yeah i could hear going on yeah
but i mean i wasn't there every sit
every single night
when we're working in the uk
those nights maybe i'd get home
because jerry would be there
but yeah yeah i did hear yeah definitely
for a fact i would i could hear
sometimes the shouting involved you know
it's most mostly i could hear amber
screaming you know
about how
i recognized this was years ago but can
you can you estimate for us how
regularly that happened
uh
i can't say regularly i can't say it was
like every day
but you know i get more regular got more
more often than not
did you ever uh
did you ever witness any physical
violence
between the two of them no no
no never i've never seen any physical
violence
it's not a thing
it's not a thing people would do in
front of security it's not a thing that
would happen in front of myself or carry
judge or sean better some it just
wouldn't happen
it wouldn't happen
no i never seen any physics physical
security i've never seen any hands-on no
okay what do you mean you never saw any
hands-on
well i never seen any slapping or
grabbing or
punching or hitting
i've never seen any of that physically i
said well
well i'll tell you what there was like
an instance maybe
two entities that come in my mind one
incidence was on a a private plane
uh i can't recall was a domestic flight
or an international flight
i'm sitting
johnny amber or johnny whoever he's
flying with will sit up at the four
tables the four table
up aft
and
myself
and my colleagues will sit down
the
furred end of the plane so i i usually
look up this useless that way
with my back to the nose
amber had her back to me johnny's
sitting across the table
and there's a big thing going on i can't
hear because you know talk about jet
craft i can't actually hear and it's
more animated than verbal
and uh
i see it i see her later a plastic
lighter
bounce off his chest boom bounce no
bounce off his chest
so right away i think well this this is
one of the escalators
see they're going to go one way or the
other
i don't think it came to much
uh
i remember johnny just us you know
smirking and looking away just to say
you know well is that it
cannot kind of attitude you know
and johnny johnny touch his heart puts
his head against the window and
whoa
i'm out you know
another time i was at the lost apartment
i was in the the security room in the
loft apartments with a
security guard called uh do you know
what i can't recall if it was sean bay
i've got a guy called donovan
anyway i got the text i would donate to
pick him up to go to
the west hollywood
accommodation
and uh
i got the text objection to the to the
extent he's going to talk about what the
text is that's hearsay
uh
you can just tell us what you observed
without looking at that without
recounting the contents of the text okay
okay i'm instructed to go and get johnny
and because we're leaving saying jack
objection he just he just said what he
was instructed to do all right i'll just
i'll stay in the objection if you can
what did you do after you received the
text
i go to the
the loft apartment
uh the doors are just slightly just like
just what you call a crack in the door
push the door open and i go and
there's about a shout and going on
i can't really i can't hear i mean i'm
in the wrong area of the apartment
but as i turn as i turn to the left into
the mud of the lounge area
there's a soda can like i i don't know i
don't know if it's a coca-cola or a
sprite or i don't know what it was
but it's launched from the mezzanine
and johnny's uh
had this huge tv
the biggest
and it's on this mechanical arm
which is an actual piece of artwork that
johnny had
got commissioned
and anyway this this big mechanical arm
holds this tv
so this kind of pop you want to call it
pop
smashes on that
but by force let me add because it means
a bang boom
and now what i can hear is that spraying
all over the place
johnny has already got his jacket on and
a bag over his shoulder
that's why he's called me in because
we're leaving
i just pick up the other bags two bags
pick up the two bags put my hands
through johnny's armor series thoughts
for leaving we walk out the door we walk
out the door and we go
halfway to s
to the
west hollywood
johnny's already calm down you know he's
like
objection objection
what mr depp is saying all right i'll
sustain objection continue uh
if you if you have uh
i i think we can move on okay all right
next question
uh just just to clarify um mr connolly
when uh
when the soda can was launched from the
mezzanine
where was mr depp in relation to where
the soda can land
10 feet 10
uh probably 10 feet back from that 10
feet back from that
okay and just to make sure we're on the
same page when you refer to the loft
departments uh what are you referring to
the downtown early eastern building
okay
um
what was your did you form any
understanding as to where um
as to who had thrown the soda can
um objection speculation okay hold on
sir speculation foundation i'm just
asking if
he formed an understanding and he can
state the basis for that if he did if
you want to lay a foundation did you did
you uh to your knowledge was miss heard
present in the apartment at the time
objection leading yes
i never seen her physically but i could
hear her voice
and and where did her could you tell
where her voice was coming from
upstairs or just upstairs
okay she wasn't on the lower the lower
apartment with us so i can only imagine
she was upstairs
other than the uh
other than the
[Music]
cigarette lighter and the soda can
anything else similar to that that you
observed
no no i can't say no no
did you ever observe any physical
injuries on this herd
never no
how about on mr down
yeah
yes
yeah it started off with maybe a
a scratch once in a while you know
a swelling but it get good more it got
more yeah i'm not talking it was marked
every every week or every two weeks but
yeah
he he he sustained marks there
definitely he was getting married
and can you describe for us
what you can
yeah um
objection you're on a queen kind of
presence
all right hold on mr connolly for a
minute
uh so mr connolly you can you can
continue uh responding i think the
question was just can you generally
describe for us what you remember about
the the marks you saw on mr depp
yes
as i was saying
in the prison service you're taught to
pick up log in your mind mental mental
logging in your mind
marks bruises bully patterns stuff
what i noticed right away was most of
these marks and most of these things
through my training
is happening in the left-hand side of
his face
and it would be scratches on his neck
maybe a a fat lip in the corner
maybe a bruising on on the eye socket
um
dull impacts you know except for
obviously the scratches maybe on these
those left ear sometimes it'd be two two
marks two lines two charms
one
yeah you know
yeah
it was getting it was getting more
regular as i say not every week but
we're definitely happening yeah
can we see um
plaintiff's exhibit
162 please
and mr connolly uh are you able to see
the picture on i assume you can see it
on your screen
yeah just gonna thank you please
yeah hi yeah
and do you uh
yeah i know that picture i took that
picture
you took pictures
yeah i took the picture
can you just quickly tell us uh what
what this picture is
this picture is a
miss head and johnny's
honeymoon
on the origin express
on the east line
from
bangkok
to singapore
you travel through malaysia stopping
kuala lumpur and a few other places on
the way down and that is in the
the dining coach i think yeah dining
coats that's what that is the guy on the
left there with a silver band around his
he's the waiter he's the waiter with the
detail to look after us
the guy in the bow tie
he's the guest relations manager mr
just hold on one second um before we
continue describing the document i'd
move for the admission of plaintiff's
trial exhibit 162 and that it be
published to the jury any objection
i'd like to approach it okay
all right and mr connolly i apologize
for cutting you off but could you just
continue to describe for us uh what
we're looking at in this picture
yeah as i said the guy in the bow tie
he's the guest relations manager he was
detailed to
you know
fixes up anything we needed
you know to excursions and
transports and stuff then it's misheard
the guy that's the chef he looked after
this he looks he cooked for the
great chef by the way
yeah he looked after us and that's
johnny and i also notice if you look at
that picture
like i said
on the left hand side under his eye
there's a swelling
and you see a swelling just on the
left-hand side of his nose and under his
left eye
and what do you interpret that swelling
to be
do what down what do i interpret as
that's uh
he's walked into a door
or a door's walked into him
okay
can you tell us anything and we can take
this down i think
thank
you uh mr connolly can you tell us uh
well first of all what uh
do you recall what year mr depp and and
miss heard went on their honeymoon uh in
the picture we were just looking at
um
that was
it i don't know 2013
2013
okay and were you uh well you testified
that you took the picture so you were
there i assume
absolutely yes
um
what can you tell us about that trip
generally and particularly focused on
how mr depp and ms heard were
interacting with each other
um started off good started off good uh
johnny's cabin was maybe
15 meters down the corridor from maine
there was no cabins in between
that was uh like store rooms like you
know blankets and cutlery and stuff
uh so
the cabin was quite
not a big massive distance but you know
it wasn't neck to me
the this chip started flying absolutely
fine
i think it was five six days five days
maybe
two days three days at the trip uh
i can see johnny going down i can see
him coming down you know
uh
he's just he's just not enjoying this
he's not enjoying us
but you know i can't it's not my
business to to step in than that i just
do my job but i can see he's not
enjoying this
like it's not he's not happy
he's not happy
did you ever observe any arguments
between mr definitely has heard in this
timeframe
just uh not arguments but uh
some frostiness mishap uh
sort of demanded that you know we have
our own
dining cat if you like
so me doing my job i inquire to the the
guest relations guy there that you've
seen in the photograph
and he quite really tells me that you
know there's other
objections
objection to hearsay all right i think
we can move on okay i'll stay in the
action next question
all right so mr uh
mr connolly um
well taking a step back for a minute and
changing topics slightly um
have you ever seen mr depp use any drugs
i don't think
i'll allow it go ahead
yes i've seen them
smoke marijuana
[Music]
i had my suspicions i have my suspicions
that when he goes off to the bathroom he
he probably does about cocaine
i've never seen him do it as mr deb
would never do
a line or anything like cocaine in front
of me or jerry judge or sean better or
anybody mr
johnny depp would never compromise my my
license my position
and embarrassed me like that it wouldn't
happen
so to answer to your question i i've
seen him smoke weed gift
he noticed any particular
what changes if any have you noticed in
his behavior when he's under the
influence of marijuana
um
to be honest
a bit more a bit more
relaxed no sort of tight but i mean he's
he's not he's not
he's not always head he's perfectly
functioning i mean
you can talk about anything any
conversation you want to talk about
he's neither up nor down with that you
know he really isn't
he's a very high tolerance for any
substance johnny you know i would say so
you know
i think jack sparrow's more drunk than
johnny depp
so okay so that's that's uh marijuana
what about alcohol same question
um alex well he used to like a wine
and the last the last um i would say the
last
couple years that's dropped drastically
as well let's say
in my last year with johnny it's quite
actually rare now it's not rare but
he's not he's not a big person though
he's not a business
and he was never he was never out his
head and when he was never you know
i think i've seen drunk in the 25 20 odd
years i've been with johnny i think i've
seen him drunk twice
and but when i say drunk i mean drunk
other than that
there's not a lot of difference in
johnny's demeanor of behavior
well you're drinking alcohol or smoking
weed you know
okay
and and finally uh
same ques same question for the time
periods when you
formed the suspicion that he was under
the influence of cocaine
sorry was that good sorry could you ask
me that again what changes in his
behavior if any did you observe on those
occasions when you suspected but didn't
know for sure that he was under the
influence of cocaine
well again
due to the training i had in
you know the
hmp prison service
it just seemed a bit uh
a bit more
i don't know
happier up
not so down you know
but i wouldn't say he's not leaping
around kicking his heels or anything he
you know you pick his guitar up and he
and then he gets he gets right into his
guitar and
there's no major changes really you know
he just
he's fine you know
okay now you mentioned you've traveled
with uh mr depp and miss heard on their
honeymoon um
in in on the orient express um
where else have you traveled with them
yeah
all over the world
japan china
germany i've been all over the states uh
went to an interest not please say
hicksville that's an interesting story
uh
yeah all over the world
australia
went to australia
as far away as that
and and uh let's let's take that one at
a time hicksville you said yeah expo
yeah um
it's uh funky
i remember it because i remember
hicksville
because it was a funky it's a real funky
place you know
uh
with the amber and uh
johnny they've decided they're going to
go to hicksville
for uh you know a day
a day and a night i think it was
so we all off the chart the amber would
have friends all head off and uh well
amber traveled with johnny but our
friends all head off
uh i followed johnny wanted to drive his
own uh
a beautiful big
customized plymouth i think it's a 58 or
50 i don't know not an expert
you had to customize do you want to
drive this this this car
myself and uh his assistant at the time
nathan holmes we
used another johnny's cars and we follow
behind
we we get to joshua tree hexville
as stunning as you can imagine
but it's a it's done in a
very funky theme
all the caravans are different themes
you know like uh it means there's an old
railway to boots
with the old foot you know the old
the
no fairground fortune teller head that
turns around and stuff johnny's and
amber's caravan were
maybe about 15 meters from mine
maybe 20 meters and it was that was done
in like the 1950s styles you know like
kitschy 1950s
kind of thing and the rest of the
caravans were all you know zombies
coming out the ground and that was
craziness
anyway we go there
there's a lot of beers all the booze
comes up
uh partly starts well sitting around in
the sun messing around party starts
so there's loads of booze and uh
weed
and i think there's mushrooms yeah
some psychedelic mushrooms
that's
going around
but the night gets a bit ruined as
as i'm watching exactly what's all
happening everybody's happy you know
johnny amber always happy
as
i'm watching what's happening i can see
johnny amber getting a bit animated
and they were probably about maybe 25
feet from me
so i
approach
and
i've been working with johnny that long
i don't have to really say anything i
only have to look at his face
and johnny can talk to me through his
face he didn't hate say a word
so i know what's happening so
like oh and i saying hello boys
guys let's keep this private let's you
know let's start walking towards the
caravan let's you know take this away
from here
as i'm walking ahead you know just you
know going ahead
i can hear
you know bickering behind me
johnny's trying of
talking you know low tone you know you
know
keep keeping a bit quiet but amber's
getting a bit more but a bit more loud a
bit more
narky
you know so anyway i get them to the
caravan i put them inside
and i go to my caravan
that's it i
don't hear anything don't see anything
until the next morning
[Music]
we sit around the pool
a couple of hours and uh we head back to
early
what prompted you
do you have a lot of direct still left
in this matter uh one
not terribly much more maybe 10
different take your afternoon break then
please jim let's go ahead and take your
15 minute afternoon break and then we'll
come back and continue with the
testimony okay
don't do any outside research and don't
talk to anybody
all right mr conley i'm going to put you
in the lobby for our break okay i'm
going to come back and put you back in
about 4 20 our time okay in about 17
minutes about 17 minutes okay sir
all right just don't discuss your test
all right just don't discuss your
testimony with anybody until then okay
okay all right thank you
all right
thank you
all right are we ready for the jury
okay
all right
all right mr connie can you hear me okay
i can't yes
can you just count to count to five for
me please
one two three four five perfect thank
you all right
next question
all right mr connolly um we were talking
about hicksville there and you made a
comment that um
you had suggested to mr depp and miss
heard that they
they keep it private or something along
those lines
uh good yes my my question is just what
prompted you to make that suggestion
well i was getting kind of uh animated
you know it was getting
animated and you know no one wants to
see the
[Music]
earth of dirty laundry in public
uh were they both animated
uh more so
amber
johnny yes but more so amber
okay
do you remember anything in particular
that ms heard was saying at the time
i don't recall no
as i say i it wasn't really coherent it
was more of the animation that you know
the
the head movements and the stern looks
and stuff that made prompting me to do
what i have to do you know
okay
uh shifting gears a little bit um
you listed out various places that you
traveled with with mr deb and miss heard
and i think you listed japan germany
hicksville and australia do i have that
right
correct yes
when were you in australia
i'll be
15 2015 uh pirates 5.
and uh
what were you doing in australia
uh
my job uh
i
in that and i
flew out first i used to fly at first to
do the advance
uh the advance includes
the checking of accommodation
not so much accommodation because nathan
holmes
uh ben king
and the chef called russell they had
already been been at the home excuse me
been at the home
and got that sorted out
my main concern was locations
transport
local security
drivers you know
making sure all that's in line before
johnny gets there
jerry judge would have traveled with
johnny in australia
on arrival uh i would have picked him up
at the airport as we do
taken to the the house
where accommodation was staying in
and uh i would i would have peeled off
the left that
went back to my apartment
johnny would have been
it could be up to a week for
you know a makeup
costume before any shooting stuff
in which time it gives me a time to run
around some locations
the studio check out the studio the
locations
as well as be around for if johnny wants
to go for dinner at night anywhere i
would check out these places as well all
right mr connolly i'm sorry i i just had
a little trouble hearing you there could
i might be the might be the connection
but could you speak maybe just a little
bit slower i'm sorry
okay
um as i say
my job in in australia is just to secure
all the advance
so i would check out make sure the local
drivers are there all the cars are in
order the accommodations in order
the locations
for shooting are all safe
liaison with production
what's expected of them
i would pick him up at the airport when
he arrives take him to accommodation
peel off go and check out a few
restaurants in case he wants to go
and if nothing's happening
stand down
for that evening
does anything stand out to you about
your time in australia in 2015
yeah johnny lost a finger
um
yeah
uh
yeah one afternoon i was uh instructed
to go to johnny's accommodation
objection and can we just
okay all right
hold on a second mr conley
all right mr mr connolly um please
continue but but as you as you go please
avoid um
the substance of any communications that
you had with mr depp uh or or his
security and just focus on what you
observed
okay
i arrived
at johnny's accommodation
was my driver andrew
i noticed that there's an suv
one of the security the the rst resident
security team
one of their vehicles is sitting outside
the door no driver
so
i just assumed
just well something up there was a
security car there but no driver
as i approached the door i hear a muffle
like a muffled
shouting and screaming and
you know
quite muffled though because the
entrance to this house there's a massive
oak door i mean it's huge
and it's got to be about 25 mil thick
so often it
and it's chaos it's uh
screaming and shouting but
oh oh i can see with my eyes is johnny
he's wearing a a
jacket
a hat
and a bag with these notebooks
i always know that bag because it's a
great canvas bag
and he's
sort of you know
nuts in one hand
so i'm saying well hey what's going on
button is screaming and shouting
madness
amber's amber's irate i mean tenacious
it's crazy stuff
johnny's uh you know shouting back
so i've said johnny let's go let's go
you know
that's my job to remove them from a
situation
let's go
i do a couple of steps for some
johnny give me five minutes now five
minutes well he's a boss you know
there's no gay there's no bullets flying
so
okay give him two minutes about i say
let's go let's go eventually i get him
out i managed to get him outside the
door
we go downstairs
but amber appears from somewhere no i
don't know if amber was upstairs or in
the room to the left or
wherever
but she appears and she's screaming
you know
screaming
berating them she's basically berating
them
like yeah [ __ ] off she's saying johnny
yeah that's what you [ __ ] off that's
what you do all the time that's all you
ever do is [ __ ] off you [ __ ] off with
your guys you're [ __ ] covered that's
what you [ __ ] do
you [ __ ] kill again [ __ ] off with
your guys your big man all that all that
[ __ ] that goes with it
get some downstairs
uh valencia members on the threshold of
the the the
the
accommodation
she's uh screaming you know [ __ ] off
your [ __ ] camera that you kind of
worked you know
and i get them in the car and i want to
sit in the same i usually sit in the
front seat shotgun i want to sit in the
same seat at the back so i can have a
look at what's going on here and have a
chat and have a talk
but when i get around the car
the driver has not locked the door
so he's out the door again and he's
making his way back up the stairs i get
back round again
by the time i get to the top of two two
concrete stairs to the front door
he's just crossing the threshold
and and the screaming start
again excuse me amber is screaming
again johnny let's go let's go
and this time it's a wee bit more force
and i managed to actually basically pull
him out of the place
get him into the car doors a lot this
time
into the car when we take off
i got them back to my apartment using uh
you know a secret way through the
underground car park and
service lifts
i get them up to my apartment
uh get him into my apartment
while she start washing his hand
basically three hours in his hand
washing the first aid
it's a mess his hand his finger's just a
mess it's like one of them cartoon
exploding cigars i was always thinking
in my mind that one of them
one of them see how that blow up you
know the cartoons boom
and uh and it's so flapping around and i
could see bone there's bone there it's
smashed a bit and he's you know he's
wincing as i'm trying to wash his hand
uh anyway i set him down and i phoned
debbie debbie and us who's living in the
same apartment both with me so that's my
first thing phone debbie
fun debbie about 20 minutes later
if that i don't recall
uh maybe 25 maybe half an hour
but she turns up with the doctor kipper
so um
dr kipper does his thing nurse debbie
dresses all but kipper is saying like
this there's no this we have to go to
the hospital this is no there's no other
way we have to go to the hospital this
has to be seriously looked at
we get to the hospital and that's when
he's uh well he that's when he's keeping
started you know
okay
um
when you
when you were in the presence of of mr
depp and miss heard in the house in
australia
um
how far away were you from miss herd
when i first entered the house miss head
wasn't visible to me
only johnny it's only when we started to
leave
this haird appeared
and she's probably
well you're talking
two feet
did you observe any injuries on this
hurt
no injuries no no
i allow it
i i'm sorry what was your answer
no injuries none
other than the injury to his finger did
you observe any injuries on mr on mr
depp
no
no
no
well
i say no
you know there was there was a mark in
his face and i i i didn't know what that
was so i never really put it down too
much
but uh in the hospital i took a
photograph
and when i look when i look at that
photograph
i can see two injuries
when we're sitting in the car
hold on mr khan
objection to the extent he's going to be
talking about what the mark is on his
since he didn't see what happened and
he's not a doctor we can't describe what
sorry
uh uh that's fine you're on a weekend
move on okay yeah all right next
question
um
i think you've generally described for
us uh
the kinds of things ms heard was saying
how would you describe her overall
demeanor when when she and mr depp were
in the in in each other's presence in
the house in australia
um
good days and bad days
well i'm sorry i mean on that particular
day
on that particular day i had never seen
him in the house that particularly the
only the time i seen
uh
miss herb and johnny in that house is
when i arrived there to extract them
and and how did miss heard seem to you
when you saw her uh on that day when you
arrived to extract him
crazy
crazy
crazy
fierce you know fierce
okay
what was the what was the last thing
miss heard said as you were taking mr
death out of the house to to go to your
apartment and then the hospital
yeah
the last one what i recall hearing is as
i'm getting johnny out is yeah just [ __ ]
off you guys you're [ __ ] covered like
you always do
all right i have no further questions
all right cross examination
huh
um
mr connolly uh
you still work for mr depp
i do yeah okay and you've worked for him
now for about 18 years
no
well two years ago you said you worked
for him for 16 years so two more years
would be 18. no i i worked with him i
didn't work for him i worked for a guy
called jerry judge and music and arts
johnny depp never paid me
johnny depp started paying me two years
ago okay so now you're being so you you
were working
jerry judge was your jerry judge was
your boss until he passed away is that
right
okay and now and now you get paid
directly by mr depp correct
right
you paid a salary by mr depp
no
okay
and you mr depths also provided you
gifts correct
gifts gifts
money gift yes
yes he's just johnny gave me guest stuff
gave johnny get and you've had she's
given you gifts over 8 500 correct
8500
yeah
you give me a lot more than that
okay and you're loyal to mr depp right
i'm yes of course i'm loyal to mr i'll
be loyal to you if it's working for you
okay
um
now going to australia
you said you went to australia in 2015
with mr deb correct
or you went before mr depp but you you
were there to work for mr depp correct
right
and jerry judge was also there
not when i wrote no but he eventually
was jerry judge was eventually in
australia correct
right and nathan holmes was also in
australia as well right
right
and mr depp came to australia in
february of 2015. correct
correct and when when
mr depp first came to australia amber
was not with mr depp right
i don't recall i don't recall bamber
arrived with johnny or
a amber arrived
you don't know one way or the other
no
and mr deputy stayed in a house in
australia correct
right and you and the security team were
about 40 minutes away from the house mr
depp was running correct
25 30.
20
30 40 yeah you could yeah you're correct
if it's a traffic day you have 40
minutes or more
and alcohol was in the house in
australia correct
and mr depp consumed alcohol before
amber arrived in australia isn't that
right
yeah he would have done yet okay and
you know if mr depp consumed illegal
drugs before amber arrived in australia
and object to speculation
and
do you know if mr depp spent any time
with marilyn manson in australia before
amber arrived
don't recall i don't recall i don't
recall marlon mansion being there
so you don't so as mr def security you
don't know if if mr depp was with
marilyn manson and i left
i left australia to smuggle two dogs
back out of australia back to you no no
no i'm talking about it i'm talking
about in the beginning of march
2015 you were that you were you were
munching you don't know one way or the
other
no
were you were you seeing mr depp every
day
in early morning
no not the beginning of duties okay
so you don't know what mr depp was doing
at that time correct
no i wasn't with him okay and you don't
know when amber arrived into uh in
australia correct
no
okay but you do know that amber stayed
with mr depp right
yes okay and you talked about a resident
security team that was at the um
australia house is that right
that's correct
and were there about four
is it
was there anyone it from the resident
security team in the house when you
arrived on
march 8 2015.
no okay and the resident security team
is it your understanding that they were
there that they were kind of guarding
the house yeah but
they would have been in the grounds but
the substantial grounds
real substantial ground
they would have hit the ground somewhere
but they didn't but they didn't go into
the house on on march 8th correct
i don't know i never seen them in the
house okay
and so when you arrived at the house and
and went and went in was it just
mr depp and amber heard
just mr that number here okay
there may be someone else here i never
visibly seen anyone else i wasn't there
long enough to chat
to anybody and when you arrived at the
house you could you could hear a ruckus
correct
yes well yes i could hear enough yeah
yeah i could hear definitely here's
something through the the the door yeah
but you said the door was so thick you
couldn't hear the actual words that were
being said is that right
no just
a shouting
and then you saw then you went in the
house and saw mr depp in the foyer
correct
yes correct and mr depp was trying to
urinate in the four year wasn't he
no
mr mr depp had his
next question and you were trying to get
mr deb out of the house correct
correct i'll try to get mr deadpool and
mr depp was refusing to leave the house
was he not
not so much refused he just wanted two
minutes to save peace you took mr depp's
arm to try to move him out but he broke
away isn't that right
yes okay i mean so he was strong enough
to break away from your grip correct
no
so
you had his arm and he broke away though
correct
no
isn't that what you just said
no i let him go you let go
yes but it wasn't easy it wasn't he's
gonna drag him
so mr depp's your boss you'll do what mr
deb wants correct
no
it's not easy to get mr deb out of the
house correct
not easy okay
now could we put can we play um exhibit
380a which is already in evidence
planos are defendants i'm sorry uh it's
defendants exhibit 380a
what what is this uh sorry what is this
and this is a recording from australia
and it's just of mr dap
i don't think that's an evidence here
hold on it's not in evidence are
plaintiffs exhibit
a i don't believe there are any
recordings from australia in evidence
here i don't think i think this is there
definitely is it's it's up just of mr
dab we can three i don't have 380 in
evidence
it's 380a3
i have jamie says it was id but never
admitted
it was never admitted it was
your honor the recordings from australia
have other voices on them asking for the
it's only the clip of mr deputy okay
it's actually plaintiff's 380 a
minute 33 to 34.
what's the foundation for using it with
this witness he was at he was at the
house
it's an evidence that's fine
so you're playing that clip correct
are and correctives you are and how do
you [ __ ] me over
and make me feel sick
of myself
did you did you hear that mr connolly
i did yes and that was the sort of
condition mr depp was in when you saw
him at the house correct
yes yes mr depp was upset and angry when
you saw him at the house correct
absolutely yes okay
now
did you take did you take mr depp to the
hospital
along with others yes
is it your testimony that mr depp was
coherent at the hospital
yes
um can you let's
show um defendant's exhibit 370 and i'd
just like you to look at something for a
moment
i'm not i'm not putting it i'm not
publishing it i just want to
show him a document defendants exhibit
370.
your honor i'm going to object on
foundation grounds the witness has not
even copied on this document i'm i'm
going to ask him a question and ask him
if
it refreshes his recollection that's all
i was going to ask him about i can i can
use any document or refresh
you can take it down
was um mr depp's finger was filled with
dirt grime and paint when you saw it
yes
and now you say you saw no bruises or
cuts on on amber on march 8 2015 correct
isn't it true that your main concern was
mr depp and getting him out of the house
correct
you were so you weren't you weren't
concentrating on amber correct
i was close enough if there was any
marks on amber's face i would have
picked that up in two minutes
as you're trying to pull as you're
trying to pull as you're trying to pull
mr depp out of the house you're you're
scanning amber for bruises and cuts
not scanning but i'm looking at it
as you're moving as you're moving mr
depp out of the house correct yes right
how do i know what she's going to lift
right
i'm watching her
when i move a client from a bar
situation a house situation i watch
what's happening around me but you're
not i know where the client is the
client's with me right the client was
with you and you're not scanning you
didn't scan miss herd's body for i scan
everything you scan everything on your
body
not everything in our body she's wearing
long sleeves from what i recall okay
um
and
at the hospital the doctor was told that
mr depp cut his finger with a knife
correct
correct yeah okay
and you understand that the damage at
the house
mr depp
at mr death's rented house amounted to
about a hundred thousand dollars correct
objection calls for speculation
i'll allow it
next question
in hicksville other than when you first
arrived you didn't go to the trailer
that mr depp and amber were saying is
that right
only when i delivered them to it right
and then after you delivered them
together
when i delivered them to it when we
first got there right we went inside and
had to look around yeah but after that
you never went inside the trailer after
that correct
correct so you have no idea what went on
in the trailer between mr depp and amber
isn't that right
i was told
but you have no idea you don't have any
personal knowledge as to why i've never
seen it right well i never seen it and
you know you have no idea how much
damage was done to the trailer correct
personal knowledge you have an idea
you have no idea what happened to amber
in the trailer isn't that right that's
correct
and you don't and and you talked about
that there was tension between amber and
mr depp you don't know what started the
fight correct
right
did you see mr depp grab another woman's
arm before they moved off to the truck
before
the fight started
no okay were you with miss were you with
the company when you were the were you
with the group
no okay
i mean i was maybe
20 feet away observing that's my job not
to get involved i don't sit with my
clients in a personal situation i'll
just observe
now
you testified
that at times you saw
marks and
bruises on mr depp
a fat lip i think you said
um
you don't have dates for those times
that you saw that right
i don't recall no you're talking that's
a long time ago you know right and you
testified in you testified in the uk in
this you testified in the uk correct
correct and you gave a witness statement
too in the uk correct
all right and and you never testified to
seeing any marks bruises or injuries on
mr depp isn't that right in the uk
i wasn't asking the uk but you never
testified that you never testified to
that right
it wasn't enough okay
now
use in the private you talked about a
private plane that you saw a plastic
lighter bounce off of mr depp's chest
correct
right and you said you saw mr mr depp
smirking and said and then he said was
that it is that right
no
okay you didn't you don't know what
started the fight there correct
correct okay
and
you talked about at the easter at the eb
at the uh lofts i think you called it in
los angeles
you saw a coke can
get thrown
somewhere in the vicinity of mr depp
correct
i've seen a can
right not a coke i couldn't tell you
what kind it was okay
and you don't know
what happened before you saw the coke
can get thrown correct
all right okay
and
you talk you talked about this picture
of um
that you took in in southeast asia
correct
right okay
and you never mentioned in the
uk matter or in your witness statement
mr depp having scratches and bruises on
the train correct
i was never prompted i was never asked
you gave a witness statement that gave
the
the what you saw in a relationship
between amber and mr depp and you never
talked about
bruises or cuts on mr on mr depp in
southeast asia correct
no i wasn't asked that okay
um now
you said oh only johnny could make
requests for a private dining car isn't
that right
i said that could
only johnny needed a private dining car
mr didn't need a private dining car
correct
that would be correct oh yeah that would
definitely be correct yeah only only
johnny depp would need a private any car
but johnny who doesn't want a private
dining car
okay
now you were not present and misheard
and misheard in mr dep's cabin on the
train right
no and if a fight occurred
and if a fight occurred in the cabin
you'd have no way of knowing about it
right
i wouldn't know and you don't know if mr
depp was
strangling this herd do you
no i wouldn't know you don't know if mr
depp had his shirt wrapped around
amber's neck do you
objection speculation communal lift
no i wouldn't know the only way i would
the only reason i would know anything in
that cabinet okay you you wouldn't know
you you answered sir sir so you answered
that all right
we can move on okay
and
um if we could put up please um
plaintiff's exhibit
120
and this is at 190 and i believe 120
has been
in evidence
120 a 120 b and 120 c so i think this
would be 120 d if it 120 d
yeah
and i would
mr connolly i'm asking you questions
about the
fourth
um
one down do you see that
um the document is hearsay i don't know
what the exception would be okay i'll
hold if you want to come forward
mr connolly um
you agree that miss hurt's been nothing
but respectful and professional to you
correct
absolutely right
okay
thank you i have nothing further all
right redirect
uh mr mr connolly very briefly uh when
you were in miss herd's presence in the
house in australia
on the day that mr depp
lost his fingertip
how far away were you from this herd
on the exit
on the the egress
about
three feet four feet more
can you estimate for us about how long
you were in this hurd's presence
you know what best way to do this is
think about it and count it out okay
15 seconds 20 seconds
how was the light
well it's australia the doors
massive that it's a wall of glass behind
them the light is absolutely fine you
couldn't get better
all right i have nothing for that all
right is this
subject to recall
i i think i think so yes your honor all
right mr connolly since you're subject
to recall did not discuss your testimony
with anybody and don't watch anything
about this case okay but you're free to
log off today
all right you're free to log off today
though sir thank you have a good day
thank you
all right your next witness
mr jenkins
yeah
mr jenkins can you hear me sir
good afternoon yes i can your honor all
right perfect thank you sir all right
if you raise your right hand for me
do you swear firm to tell the truth
under penalty of law
i do all right thank you sir
good morning mr jenkins can you hear me
okay
yes i can
and could you please state your full
name for the record
startling jenkins iii
and mr jenkins where do you live
los angeles california
and what is your occupation
executive chauffeur security
and how long have you worked as an
executive chauffeur and in security
executive chauffeur for 30 years secured
security
for eight years
and and what occupations did you hold
prior to working as an executive
chauffeur and and in security
route sales executive
and united states marines
mr jenkins do you know the point if in
this case johnny depp
yes i do and when did you first meet mr
depp
1993
how did you first meet mr dab
he is delivery service to transport him
to and from
so in in the 30 or so years that you've
known mr depp what services have you
performed for him
over the course of that period
child care animal care
personal assistant duties security and
transportation
and could you estimate approximately how
many hours per week would you provide
those services to mr depp
40 to 60 hours
and can you describe generally your
interactions with mr depp in the time
that you've worked for him
pleasant always upbeat
do you know the defendant in this case
amber heard
yes
when did you first meet miss hurd
after the filming of the rum diary
project
can you describe generally your
interactions with miss heard
pleasant claw joe very respectful
and so in your time working with mr depp
did you uh ever observe mr depps and
miss hurt's interactions with one
another
yes
and can you describe those interactions
generally please
very cordial very
aware that people are around them very
very friendly
did you ever see them argue
yes
can you describe what you observed about
those arguments
it would be initiated by her
she would try to engage with him he
would tell me to turn the music on
so um where did these arguments take
place
in the car
do you recall how many times you
witnessed them argue
twice
mr jenkins turning your attention to
april 21st 2016.
uh can you tell the jury what you recall
about that day
did you repeat the question here
sure so turning your attention to april
21st 2016.
can you tell the jury what you recall
about that day
it was the birthday party being held at
the penthouse
and when you say the penthouse what are
you referring to
it's the eastern columbia building
and what were you doing that evening
that evening i was assigned security on
the detail
were you inside the residence uh while
the birthday party was taking place
i was in the cp the command post that's
stationed on the same floor right
outside of the elevator
and did you interact with miss heart at
all that evening
yes i did
in regards to getting her clients
keys
parking
making sure no one else was on the floor
that wasn't invited to the party
were there any issues at the birthday
party at the time
that you were present at the penthouses
no issues except for the boss did not
show up and do you recall what time you
left that day
11 15 p.m that evening
mr jenkins what happened the next day
april 22nd 2016.
i arrived early 10 45
i went upstairs to the penthouse i was
informed by amber that she got in the
fight with johnny last night
she threw his personal property over the
balcony
into the streets ninth and broadway
and when you say personal property what
are you referring to
his phone wallet
credit cards passports everything that's
in his wallet
did uh ms hurd say anything else to you
about this altercation
nothing except she
they were fighting
so what what did you do after miss heard
informed you that she'd thrown mr depp's
personal property off the balcony
formulated a plan with norm from the
office to use the find my phone app
hit the streets and
try to get lucky
did you end up finding mr depp's phone
yes i did skid row
probably six miles from the house
and who had the who had the phone
a
homeless gentleman unhoused gentleman
i approached him about the phone he was
honest he returned it i gave him a
reward for it and what was the reward
420
chicken tacos chips apples fiji water
so after finding mr depp's phone what
did you do
i returned to the penthouse showed the
phone to amber that i retrieved it i
left it in the sheet in the cp for the
evening security to return it to mr
death
so after figuring out uh things with the
phone what what happened next
what happened next is i walked amber to
the car we got everybody in the car
she's on her way to coachella i went
back to the penthouse to retrieve the
dogs and the luggage
were you also going to coach hello with
miss heard
yes i was i was the transportation for
amber and her friends while she was at
coachella
so how did you get to coachella
enjoy the suv
provided by johnny
with the animals and all the luggage in
and headed out
to the bin
and the the morning of april 22nd did
you see uh any injuries on misheard
no marks
no engines
um and so
driving out to coachella did anyone
drive with you
i was in the car alone except for the
end
and how did miss heard get to coachella
she drove a mustang was anyone else in
her car
she was with i believe her sister and
one other friend her assistant
and do you know how many days uh miss
heard and her friends were planning to
stay at coachella
so the following monday i believe it's
the 25th of april
we departed
and do you recall where miss heard was
staying at coachella
we're staying at the parker
boutique hotels there in palm springs
outside of coachella were you also
staying at the parker hotel
i also stayed there
and so did you attend coachella for work
or for pleasure
for work
and what was your job that weekend
provide security and transportation
animal care
amber is rolling assistant take care of
her whatever she needed while she was
there at the parker or in the out trap
do you recall what time approximately
you arrived at the parker hotel on april
22nd
around
5 30 maybe quarter to six and and what
did miss hurt and her friends do that
evening april 22nd
that evening
we arrived
we were assigned the rooms we went with
the
with the
staff of the parker hotel around to the
suites where we were staying they let us
in
we let all the luggage in
and we proceeded to
[Music]
plan for that evening to depart by seven
7 15 is to get to the festival then
and and how did ms hurd and her friends
get from the hotel to the festival that
evening
i drove them directly to them
and did you have any discussions with ms
heard on the way to coachella that
evening
we had a conversation pertaining to the
surprise she left in the boss's bed
prior to leaving the apartment and when
you refer to the surprise in the boss's
bed what are you referring to
the defecation
and what did miss heard say about the
defecation in mr duff's bed
a horrible practical jerk gone wrong
mr jenkins what observations did you
make about miss heard at coachella in
april 2016
she had no worry she was there to whoop
it up it's her birthday she's with her
friends
and how often were you with her that
weekend
was with her every day she went to the
venue from the time that we interacted
with the wallet incident
the night before at the party all the
way until monday we returned
with the pets
and the luggage
and did you uh observe anything about
miss heard's health that weekend
she got sick
do you know what's sick at the venue
second night do you know what cause
missed her to be sick
she was eating the magic mushrooms and
drinking red wine on an empty stomach
and uh how do you know that she drank
red wine and took magic mushrooms
i saw the room service and i went to
their room to collect them to take them
out that evening so is that something
excuse me is that something you
witnessed
i witnessed it
and what did you do uh in response to
miss heard being sick at coachella
i collected her
[Music]
got her in the vehicle
she didn't want anybody else to know
that she was sick take her back to the
parker alone i took her to the 7-eleven
where i retrieved hydrating fluids advil
and
better have those got her back to the
parker got her into the suite and then
went back to pick up everyone else
and mr james when you said uh miss heard
got sick do you recall what her symptoms
were
yeah she was throwing up
mr jenkins did you see any injuries of
any kind i misheard april 22nd 2016.
no injury i'll sustain you so yes
what about the rest of that weekend mr
jenkins any injuries that you saw
no injuries
um
have you ever witnessed any physical
abuse between mr depp and ms heard
no
thank you mr jenkins nothing further all
right cross-examination
good afternoon mr jenkins
good afternoon so just just to be clear
on the chronology um you met mr depp in
1993 is that right
correct and you've worked for him ever
since
off and on yes okay and your your
salaries paid by mr depp correct
salaries
no
you receive pay for the work that you do
for mr yes correct of course yes of
course and what mr depp's security is
your highest priority in your job
correct
yes you do you're loyal to mysteries
you're loyal to mr depp right
yes
now i want to turn to the the
the night of april 21st 2016.
you
just just to recap you said you were
working a security shift at
amber's birthday
at the eastern columbia building that
evening correct
correct and you said that your shift
ended around 11 15
correct
correct
and
you you said the boss still hadn't shown
up by the time that you left the eastern
columbia building right
correct
so you have no idea
where mr depp was or what he was doing
from 9 30 p.m that evening until
at least 11 15 when you left the eastern
columbia building right
no i do know what he's doing he was
attending to his mother
you weren't with him
i had information okay
all right
that's information that you
that you received but you you have no
personal knowledge of that
i have no reasons i have no reason to
doubt it it came from sean okay
oh
okay so mr mr bet told you
that boss is out there right mr bett
told you that he was tending to his
mother that night
he didn't say mother he said the boss
was out late i'm aware of what the
situation was the time frame
he's with his mother
okay all right interesting okay
um
and did you have any understanding that
he had a meeting with his new business
manager earlier that evening where he
was told that he was running out of
money and that his taxes hadn't been
paid in years did you have any
understanding of that objection for
anyone else objection foundation culture
speculation i'll sustain the objection
next question
and you didn't see mr depp that night
right
no i didn't know
so you came back the next morning to
escort amber to coachella
right yes and you say that amber told
you that she had thrown
mr depp's phone off the roof
correct and did you come to understand
that
mr depp had thrown her phone off the
roof that evening prior to when amber
threw mr depp's phone off the roof
she informed me of that okay she
informed you of that so when you went
outside to look for mr depp's phone you
you weren't looking for miss herd's
phone were you
she had her phone she had her phone she
was trying to
redownload and back it up okay so she
you were only looking for mr depp's
phone when you went when you went
downstairs to this to the to uh
to try to you found it with a with an
unhoused person you said correct
correct okay and you did you did i hear
you right that you said it was six miles
away where you found the phone
correct
it actually wasn't six miles away it was
it was actually right below the building
the ecb building correct okay let's not
can you pull up um
does he have a way to see documents that
just just him your honor yes
um could you please pull up uh
the witness statement mr jenkins mr
jenkins do you do you remember giving
testimony on mr depp's behalf in the uk
trial
yes i did
and
um you gave you gave a witness statement
first in in writing correct do you
remember that
yes and then you were examined um by the
attorneys in the trial correct
correct okay
can you see on your screen the statement
uh that's
do you see a witness statement
yes i see it it says witness statement
of starling jenkins right
right and this is the statement that you
wrote and signed as part of the uh the
uk trial on behalf of mr depp correct
correct okay
if you can scroll please to page three
of the document
and
mr jenkins i'm going to read you
what you wrote in paragraph 13.
um okay
and
we can go from there um on paragraph 13
you wrote
in your witness statement in the uk
trial
the find my iphone application indicated
that johnny's phone was somewhere on the
streets below the balcony of the
residence
did i read that right
if that's what it says that's what it
says i'm telling you the phone was in
skid row okay so photo of the gentleman
that found it i have the location where
the phone was found isn't skid row just
a few blocks away from the eastern
columbia building
no it's uh it's on sixth and
man i guess depending on what error you
are okay so so one of these two sworn
statements either what you just said in
court just now that it was found six
miles away or this one of these is false
correct
uh it's
it's just inadequate as far as the
location the location is not below
the the penthouse it's not on broadway
it's found on broadway by the unhoused
man and then he lives off of skid row
okay
now let's move on to coachella please
you yes you were with uh amber and her
friends that weekend at coachella um and
you testified a little bit about what
you saw
is it fair to say that amber and her
friends were having a good time that
weekend
yes it was and there were thousands of
other people at that music festival too
correct
correct okay to your to you
were you aware that amber's sister
whitney was
pregnant and sober that weekend
wasn't my information was my knowledge
were you aware that amber's sister
whitney threw up in a parking lot that
weekend
no okay to your knowledge and
understanding mr jenkins um there's
nothing wrong with wanting to spend time
with your friends at a music festival
after being abused by your husband right
what abuse
that's not an abnormal thing to want to
be around your friends correct
she was partying up with her friends she
was partying it up and you said you
didn't hear anything about she didn't
say anything to you about domestic
violence having taken place correct
nothing in the car pertaining to that
would it surprise you that she might not
want to talk to someone who had worked
for her husband for around 23 years at
that point about domestic violence would
that surprise you
objection speculation your honor sustain
the objection next question
mr texted you on may 12
2016 asking you to call her correct
correct
and you did not bother to respond to
that text correct
correct
and that was the last communication that
you had with her
correct correct
now you weren't um just to be clear you
weren't at amber's house on orange
avenue in march 2013 when johnny was
there correct
i might have driven him to the location
i'm familiar with the address
but you didn't enter the house at any
point in march 2013 correct
depending on if you had luggage or gifts
going upstairs i might have but you
didn't hang out with them inside the
house
right
hurry up and wait in the car sir
and you weren't at the hicksville
trailer palace in late may or early june
2013 right
no
you weren't on a plane flight from
boston to los angeles in may 2014
correct with with johnny and amber
you weren't in the you weren't with mr
depp and amber in the bahamas in august
2014 correct
correct
you weren't with mr death and amber in
tokyo in january 2015 correct
uh no i was not there correct you
weren't with mr depp and amber in
australia in march 2015 correct
correct you weren't at thanksgiving with
them in penthouse five of the eastern
columbia building in november 2015
correct
uh
i believe i was there you didn't
detail i don't have the schedule but i
might have been assigned the detail that
day you want it's a holiday sure sure
you don't have any specific recollection
of that one way or the other though
correct
i would probably say i was on duty that
day okay it's the holiday okay um you
weren't celebrating thanksgiving in
penthouse five with them that evening
correct
i was in the cp okay and that's that's a
separate room correct
separate room on the same level correct
and you weren't in the bahamas in late
december 2015 correct
with them correct you weren't in the ecb
with just the two of them the night of
december 15 2015 correct
that is uh
right before the christmas party i
believe
correct
and finally you weren't in the penthouse
of the eastern columbia building on the
night of may 21st 2016 with mr depp and
miss heard correct
and and and you'd agree that you have no
personal knowledge of what went on
between mr depp and mrs heard behind
closed doors correct
correct
nothing further thank you all right
redirect
just very quickly on your honor do we
have
mr jenkins witness statement
or perhaps
and if we could go to the third page
please
uh mr jenkins directing your attention
to paragraph 13 which mr rottenborn had
you look at just a second ago
he read the first sentence of that
witness statement
um
to find my phone find my iphone
application indicating that giant's
phone was somewhere on the streets
before the balkan residence walked out
could you could you please read for the
jury the the second part of the
that paragraph
i walked out onto the street did not see
the phone i then
asked several homeless people but they
had the phone one homeless man admitted
to me that he had the phone returned the
phone to me in exchange for the
following
425 in cash three chicken tacos two bags
of chips four apples two apples four
bottles of water
and so do you do you recall where you
found the iphone that day
yes i do objection asked and answered
all right i'll sustain the objection
next question
mr jenkins moving to uh coachella
mr rottenborn asked you about um
whitney heard do you know who that is
yes i do do you know the difference
between whitney heard and amber heard
yes i do and who was sick that was the
boss
who was sick that day at coachella
amber was sick
thank you nothing further all right is
this witness subject to recall
know your honor all right mr jenkins
you're um
you're free from testimony and therefore
you're free to to do whatever you need
to do or you can watch the proceedings
it's up to you but uh you're you're done
for today though thank you sir
thank you ronnie thank you for the court
all right have a good day
you're awesome all right
all right i think it's close enough to 5
30 that i think we've had enough
of a week
ladies and gentlemen at this time we're
going to go ahead and
be done with the testimony for this week
although since i won't see until monday
i want to give you
the long jury instruction that i give
you every every thursday evening just so
we all remember our responsibilities
okay
so at this time remember that you are
not to read anything about this case you
are not to watch anything about this
case you are not to listen to anything
about this case this applies to
television newspapers magazines the
internet and any online sites
further you are not to read watch or
listen to anything about this case on
any social networking sites such as
twitter facebook instagram snapchat
blogs or similar sites in addition you
must not communicate with anyone about
the case whether in person over the
phone by email text or instant messaging
or by any other electronic or
non-electronic means this includes your
friends family co-workers acquaintances
and strangers i also instruct you that
you cannot do any research or make
inquiries about this case whether online
or by any other means for example you
cannot look uh look information up on
the internet that is related to this
case or related to the persons involved
in this case normally you consult
dictionaries or other reference
materials what you learn about this case
is limited to what you learn in the four
walls of this courtroom when proceedings
are underway you also may not
communicate about this case or the
person's involved in this case with your
fellow jurors okay hope you have a good
weekend it's supposed to be great
weather on saturday go outside get some
fresh air okay and just enjoy your
weekend and we'll see you back monday at
10 okay thank you so much
all right
and as always mr mr depp and ms heard
please do not do any posting on social
media and do not talk to the press i
appreciate it and have a good weekend
for the attorneys tomorrow
um what time how many did we do our
homework this week yes
we did
work in progress okay so are we still
doing
19 tomorrow
20s you added one for me that's lovely
okay great so we'll do 20 tomorrow so i
would suggest 8 o'clock can everybody be
here at eight sound good
okay we'll be here at 8 am and we'll
just do them until we're done so bring a
lot of meals okay
all right we'll see you tomorrow then
thank you have a good evening
[Music]
you